ARE JUST SO OUTRAGED THAT
ELON MUSK IS TAKING OVER
TWITTER, THEY'RE DITCHING
IT.
"GREY'S ANATOMY" CREATOR
SHONDA RHIMES IS AMONG
THOSE ANNOUNCING TO THE
WORLD THEY'RE QUITTING
TWITTER.
HE VOWED TO MAKE SWEEPING
CHANGES, INCLUDING
RESTORING FREE SPEECH AND
POTENTIALLY REVERSING THE
BAN ON FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
PIERS MORGAN SAID HE
EXPOSED A BUNCH OF LIBERAL
CRY BABIES AND SAID THAT
HE GO BE BACK.
WE SAW THE SAME HYSTERIA
WHEN DONALD TRUMP BECAME
PRESIDENT IN 2016 SHGZ AND
THE LIKES OF THESE
CELEBRITIES VOWED TO LEAVE
AMERICA IN FURY AND
DESPAIR AND ALL STAYED.
I DELTA VARIANTLY PREDICT
NONE OF THOSE SCREAMING I
QUIT WILL STOP THEMSELVES
FROM TWEETING FOR LONG.
THEY'RE TOO ADDICTED TO
THE APPROVING ATTENTION
AND SOUND OF THEIR OWN
PERMANENTLY WHINEY VOWSES.
DAVID, HE NAILED IT.
>> I LOVE THIS.
WE TALKED ON BREAK ABOUT
STEPHEN KING THAT WAS
GOING TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY
AFTER TRUMP WAS ELECTED.
HE IS STILL HERE.
NOBODY CARES IF ONE PERSON
LEAVES TWITTER.
WHY?
IF THEY HAVE 60 MILLION
FOLLOWERS, THE OTHER 60
MILLION ARE LIKELY TO STAY
THERE, THAT'S WHAT MATTERS
TO TWITTER'S BUSINESS
MODEL.
THIS STORY AND PROCESS
TOOK 207 DAYS FOR
ACQUISITION, IT WILL
REVERBERATE FROM BUSINESS
AND CULTURAL STANDPOINT,
DOMESTIC AND GLOBAL.
IT IS A GLOBAL PLATFORM.
SO THEY'RE NOT GOING
ANYWHERE.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, THEY
NEED TWITTER, THEY NEED TO
FEED THEIR EGOS AND TWEETS
ABOUT THEIR DOGGY,
HAIRSTYLE, WHATEVER LATTE
THEY'RE DRINKING, THEY'RE
NOT GOING ANYWHERE, THEY
NEED IT FOR THEIR
BUSINESS.
WITHOUT TWITTER AND
FEEDBACK FROM FOLLOWERS,
WHAT DO THEY GET?
THEY GET A CHECK, THEY ACT
IN A MOVIE, BUT WHAT DO
THEY REALLY GET.
>> RIGHT.
>> LEAVE TWITTER.
THEY'LL BE BACK.
>> SO HE BROUGHT UP
STEPHEN KING WHO SAID YOU
SHOULD PLAY ME TO HAVE THE
BLUE CHECK MARK.
THE POINT IS THE PUBLIC
CONVERSATION, IF THE POINT
IS INFORMATION TRANSFER OR
PUBLIC SQUARE, WE DON'T
CARE IF CELEBRITIES LEAVE.
IT IS NOT A GAME.
DON'T CARE IF THE ATHLETE
LEAVES, NOT A POPULARITY
CONTEST, DON'T CARE IF THE
PROM KING LEAVES, IT IS A
CONVERSATION TO RENDER ALL
VOICES EQUAL, NOT TO GIVE
HIGHER WEIGHT TO THE
NOVELIST.
>> IT IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF CELEBRITIES THINKING WE
GIVE A CRAP ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE THINKING.
I COULDN'T CARELESS WHO IS
ON TWITTER, THEY'RE ALSO
HYPOCRITES, THEY'RE NOT
NOTICING THAT KANYE WEST
OR YE IS STILL OFF TWITTER
BECAUSE OF HIS DESPICABLE,
ANTI-SEMITIC REMARKS.
IT IS NOT LIKE PEOPLE ARE
ALLOWED TO SAY THINGS LIKE
THAT.
THERE ARE COMMENTS THAT
SHOULDN'T BE ON THERE, BUT
IT IS FREE SPEECH AND
PEOPLE ARE DUE TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES, WHETHER YOU
ARE A CONSERVATIVE OR
DEMOCRAT.
UNFORTUNATELY CELEBRITIES
AND DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT
REPUBLICANS TO HAVE FREE
SPEECH, THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
BEING CRY BABIES.
>> I WILL HAVE KAYLEIGH
GET IN HERE, WHY IS IT
CELEBRITIES PROTEST
RESTORATION OF FREE SPEECH
WHEN THE AYATOLLAH AND
ANTI-SEMITIC VOICES ARE
ALLOWED TO FESTER ALL THIS
TIME, WHERE WAS THEIR
PROTEST.
>> IT IS INTERESTING.
YOU HAVE MOMENTS THAT
CRYSTALLIZE WHO LIBERALS
ARE, LIKE COVID-19 HITS
AND YOU SEE ALL THESE
CRAZIES, KNEW SOME SHUT
DOWN CHURCHES, USED IT TO
RESTRICT THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
ELON MUSK SAYS FIRST
AMENDMENT, FREE SPEECH,
WHAT DO THE TROLLS DO,
THEY HATE FREE SPEECH.
ALL HE SAID IS I WANT FREE
SPEECH.
AND TAYLOR LORENZ, LIKE
THE GATES OF HELL OPENED
ON THE SITE.
TWITTER IS TO BE TAKEN
OVER BY THE EVIL SITH
LORD.
ALL HE WANTED WAS FREE
SPEECH.
DAN RATHER, A QUESTION I
AM ASKING, IF I GO THERE
WILL BE TROUBLE, IF I STAY
THERE WILL BE DOUBLE.
>> WHO?
>> DAN RATHER.
NO ONE CARES, DAN.
>> THE MSNBC COMMENTATOR
WHO IS A LAWYER WHO SAID
STAY, I DON'T KNOW IF SHE
WAS REFERRING TO LYRICS.
TRISTAN SNELL AFTER NEWS
BROKE THAT ELON MUSK
BOUGHT TWITTER SAID HOWED
YOUR GROUND LIKE A
UKRAINIAN TO THOSE WHO
WERE POTENTIALLY GOING TO
LEAVE.
I'M SORRY, WHAT?
YOU ARE BASICALLY GOING TO
COMPARE ILLEGAL
INAGGRAVATION BY A RUSSIAN
DICTAT
DICTATE
O
ORA
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM
BEING BOUGHT BY A
CONSERVATIVE.
>> LET ME -- JUST A
MINUTE.
CONSIDER THAT YOU WOULD BE
STATING THIS IS YOUR
POSITION THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO ABANDON A PLATFORM
SIMPLY BECAUSE OTHER
PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO
SPEAK UP.
WHO DOES THAT?
WHO REALLY DOES THAT.
IN THE SCHEME OF THINGS WE
KNOW IN THIS CITY, WE'RE
IN THIS CITY, PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THINGS NONE OF US
WOULD LIKE, BUT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO SEND THE POLICE
TO SHUT THEM UP.
WE CAN'T HEAR THEM,
THEY'RE HERE.
WE CAN'T STOP THOSE
BELIEFS.
FACT OF MATTER IS IF YOU
WANT TO STOP SOMETHING,
YOU DON'T LIKE IT, YOU DO
CONFRONT IT RHETORICALLY
TO MAKE IT IRRELEVANT OR
TO AT LEAST SHOOT IT DOWN,
BUT THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T.
THIS IS ABOUT THE LEFTIST
NARRATIVE.
IT IS NOT ABOUT NOT LIKING
THE AYATOLLAH OR ISIS OR
OTHERS ON TWITTER, IT IS
ABOUT MAINTAINING THAT
SINGULAR NARRATIVE LINE
THAT'S LIBERAL, THAT'S
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
IT IS ABOUT CONSERVATIVES.
IT IS NOT ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
ARE RACIST OR BIGOTS OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT, IT IS
ABOUT TAKING THIS MORAL
GROUND THAT THEY ONLY IN
HABIT THAT GROUND, BUT THE
EQUIVALENT WOULD BE IF WE
LOOKED AT TWITTER WOULD BE
FOR US TO SEND MOBS TO THE
HOUSES OR APARTMENTS OF
PEOPLE WHO THINK THINGS
THAT WE DON'T LIKE TO MAKE
SURE THEY CAN'T LIVE THEIR
LIVES.
IT IS CANCEL CULTURE, BUT
THAT IS WHAT THEY WANT.
THEY WANT TO NORMALIZE IT
AND DO IT THROUGH TWITTER.
>> AND THE BLUE CHECK WAS
SUPPOSED TO SYMBOLIZE A
PERSON OF PUBLIC INTEREST.
I ARGUE THAT PERSON IS THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN.
THE PUBLIC INTEREST IS
RAISED WITH SOMEONE WHO
KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT IT IS
LIKE TO FEEL THE EFFECTS
OF INFLATION, MAKE
DECISIONS THAT ARE TOUGH,
LIKE HAVING TO TAKE OUT A
LOAN FOR SCHOOL SUPPLIES,
THOSE